[Music]
shitty prank news submitted by Keanu
from Florida a YouTube minister is
facing prison for giving a homeless man
a toothpaste filled Oreo what that's
like an old joke
yeah just for toothpaste for winter he's
allergic to toothpaste more chocolate gl
Oreos are chocolate I don't know yeah
yeah the chocolate cookie and then the
cream in the middle now we thought they
was I never it doesn't really taste like
chocolate does if you just taste the
cookie it tastes like cocoa wait why is
toothpaste in a hurry I'm gonna put the
kid in prison man well I think let's
think back to this country Protestant
regardless of what it is I'm so happy
because I used to love pranks on YouTube
but now I [ __ ] hate all pranks and I
don't like youtubers pick out homeless
people they're funny social experiments
but you have to call mass with the
vernacular yes they're really funny
social speak with the toothpaste in the
Oriole what's your bet yeah hey you
wanna Oreo that's like yeah you want
that you really want to and they're
doing it to homeless people who are in
like a desperate situation I want to see
him do like cops or something
someone will flock here excuse me
another shield bring them what's the
[ __ ] yeah hey you would try real shitty
Oreo well I want to see them get tasered
or something that's like hey you like
brownies everyone loves me yeah of
course I love my menu but it's [ __ ] take
all the go to somebody in a [ __ ]
snowy cabin tied them up to some bungee
cords and fly them out the roof oh my
god yeah did some very nice-looking like
40 year old Japanese man he's so tired
cuz he's been all day traveling he gets
into his hotel room he goes eat late he
takes off all his clothes and he lays
down in a nice silk bed and all of a
sudden the back of the whole room opens
up he looks back do a [ __ ] sled the
whole bed becomes the sled and he goes
down a Snowden Bank mint it hits a
[ __ ] ramp you saw this oh yeah dude
David was showing me the [ __ ]
no no David show me it and these guys
are so worried looking it
crowd of literally less Japanese people
understand what pranks are it's so good
if it's going to be dumb and petty it
has to be like something you can't even
think of yeah like following a man for a
year and somehow laid trap to haven't
done into a boiling hot water oh my gosh
they bring out a bucket of ice so he
could sit on it so he as he crawls out
of it that is hilarious
I like the elevator one turn into a
slide and in a slow-mo they just [ __ ]
press it and just the floor just open
it's amazing because because and what's
in the best part about it too is while
this guy is so worried it actually
scared for his life as he slides down
this thing right an audience full of
Japanese people are watching and
laughing and like live on camera it's
the best and the host is laughing with
the microphone it's so good and that
just shows Japanese people know how to
take a [ __ ] joke yeah there you go I
like that this guy here and they'll sue
ya no no like we would alright so this
is a Chinese youtuber that is based in
Barcelona his name is Kang wah Ren
sounds like a great restaurant it says
in the video he fills up the Oreo with
toothpaste and then walks up to this
random homeless dude he's like hey and
then he asked him like how much money is
the most money you've gotten from
someone he's like I don't know and then
he ends up handing him like 20 euros and
then he's like aw thank you so much and
then he ends up giving him this bag of
Oreos that was already open like this
screenshot from the video and this is
when he was preparing it and [ __ ] that
guy this dude who wears blue contacts oh
oh he's trying to [ __ ] building a brand
because I really uh Rogan Paul that's my
hero
so he's born in China but he lives in
Barcelona so this video wasn't Spanish
oh yeah so um wrong exit I wonder what a
Chinese Spanish exit sounds like maybe
he doesn't have a Chinese accent oh I
never hear a Chinese Ora
oh wow that's dudes 20 if you care to
say he's 20 Oreo so that video went
viral
there's tons of people pissed off so you
ever see me like it went viral yeah
oh no because the dude as soon as he's
been into it he starts throwing up and
then this [ __ ] kids up saying maybe I've
gone a bit far but look at the positive
side this will help him clean his teeth
I think he hasn't cleaned them since he
became poor that's what it just goes
this is uh he uh probably [ __ ] lights
snails on fire these are the kids who
are like look I know there's a line and
I have sex with the line of guy [ __ ] it
yeah I'm really extreme it's like okay
we get it good you're crazy
he was recording him just eating that
[ __ ] and puking yeah that's pretty sad
so the homeless guy was like what the
[ __ ] is this or he didn't say anything I
didn't see the full video since I was
taken down but like from the little clip
dice off in the media I didn't see that
after like the reaction after is just
being reported that the homeless dude
was throwing up and then this being hip
reported his quote after so I didn't
personally see it so I don't know what
else he did after that um what are the
police charging him with if he is found
guilty yeah it would be a of a crime
against moral integrity he would be
fined thirty seven thousand US dollars
yeah yes a lot money we need laws like
this moral integrity laws no thank you
they're also demanding yes yes yes in
prison I disagree with I please do this
that's Joe Mallya right for these please
I think what do you know what if it was
funny I would have been like cool no I
agree it's not funny but I can't feel
people in jail for not being funny I
can't yeah my punishment yeah I don't
know that's a good question because I
don't know I mean this is just a stupid
thing like it he got really unlucky
because this guy had a weird reaction to
it but the bid is dumb that's what I'm
saying he should go to jail for that
[ __ ] for being for having to dump it yep
he shut dude
because if it was really good I'd pay
him 37,000 but how was he gonna get to
the good house it was I'm not defending
it but how is he ever gonna get good if
he doesn't start so he needs to practice
without doing it on people exactly he
needs to practice on Fran advantage
that's the place where he started normal
Hey look I don't think doing Vince the
homeless people any good at all look I
think that's morally locked up yeah I
think so but but that's you know I think
those practical joke things are [ __ ]
up though like well the issue that I
have what this is kind of I guess it's
kind of a poison to dude
exactly well he doesn't I mean that's
not chemical warfare did apparently he
also gave the homeless dude 300 euro to
stay quiet or he offered that amount of
money so what the homeless dude do call
the cops
so the homeless dude was thinking like
he was he says that he was afraid for
his life because he didn't know who this
kid was and what he put in it yeah what
he put in there what do you put in there
the fact that he's giving him money to
stay quiet
kids [ __ ] Asian a blue eyes he's ugly
as [ __ ] can't trust them utterly part
pug threw him off the boat he throw up
on his face
you should have fed that [ __ ] to his mom
first and then she could have bet beat
his ass stopped it there that's true you
start with them all you do you always
try out the family prank when you're
growing up trying to be a comedian or
whatever you practice on your friends
and family first and if it sucks there
then you don't pursue a life of comedy
let's do that more than a million
subscribers damn a million Spaniards
what did his fans think whatever they
like this is your best thing ever they
were they were mad oh good for them yeah
they're busy this is what happens when
people don't evolve you know I mean they
do the same bit over and over and over
and they get desperate and so they try
to do anything give you that bit is as
old as Oreos man you see it a lot better
it's more as old as the [ __ ] you
don't have to have the Buzzard you shake
hands and you [ __ ] shot go see it on
YouTube all the time like these kids
they get one spark right and they're
like this is what I known for and that's
all they can do and then three months
later they're still doing the same thing
and they're sitting there they're like
why am I not getting views why am i why
are people not looking and why don't
people laughing anymore
cuz you just said the same joke 14 times
a week like we're tired of it now this
is kind of crazy dude I don't get it
you know what European prankster I love
the guy
that was a snail and he held up traffic
I love that by being a [ __ ] said all
that trigger-happy TV [ __ ] made me mad I
didn't they played like Mario Cart like
all over the neighborhood I love when a
it's like the they have a guy in a
rabbit costume and I have a guy in a
turtle costume and the Turtle costume
guys are moving very slowly and the
rabbit guy is like laughing and being
all cocky and [ __ ] I love all yeah I'm
child like could you imagine if every
single one of your guys's videos was
Uncle Sam and uncle Chan but for the for
[ __ ] like 10 years yeah like where
the [ __ ] would your career be right now
you know I mean it's just come on I mean
Tyler Perry did it you might have made a
movie they meant I had six movies by now
and or one specific audience yeah it's
pretty crazy because I think everybody's
trying their best to find some attention
to get famous on YouTube to like do the
thing and he got a million doing
something but then this is like this
weird [ __ ] manifestation because he's
deaf he might be going to jail for yeah
cuz we know people that are like oh they
started off doing social experiments or
whatever and they're like really
desperate at a certain point when they
run out of content they start doing
weird [ __ ] like hey look at me
please I'm still relevant yeah and the
sex goes like I think like that's such a
short-sighted way to live your life
because you're basing who you are in
your value on what other people think
about you shock you know what other
people think about you always changes
that's right yeah you know and it's it's
hard living like that man
explicit if you're a young person you're
watching this you're gonna find out that
is the worst way to live and every time
somebody says you're not doing something
good you're gonna be sad every time
somebody's give you a pat on the [ __ ]
back you're gonna be sad living for the
comments dude it's the worst [ __ ] ever
yeah it's got do it for yourself man
[Music]